hi there i'm lottie winter the beauty
editor of glamour uk
today i'm going to be trying botox and
for my procedure
i'm going to go and visit dr michael
prager
i've tried botox before but any
treatment should start with a
consultation ask your doctor if there's
any aftercare that you need to do
or anything that you may need to be
aware of after your treatment is
finished
botox is actually a muscle relaxant so
that's how it was discovered
and the cosmetic side effect was just a
byproduct
of the muscle relaxation effect i
grind my teeth at night really really
badly and it results in a lot of neck
pain and headaches so
botox can really help with that and also
help relieve migraines through frowning
and stress
but also obviously as a kind of
preventative aging
process for me that's also another
benefit
the botox is admittedly a poison but
it's injected in a minute amount into
the muscle it takes
a couple of days and then the muscle
relaxing effect kicks in
okay so it was a little bit painful but
only at the exact
moment the needle went in as soon as the
injection
was finished i didn't feel any pain
i am quite particular when i choose my
practitioner for cosmetic treatments i
always want to see
a qualified doctor i also always go to a
clinical setting
i know that sometimes you can go and
have
you know botox treatments at home or
kind of in a traveling clinic
i don't do that because i think that
knowing someone's
address the clinic address adds a layer
of accountability
so that if something goes wrong you know
exactly where you can go
how do you choose your botox
practitioner
i think make sure that he's not one of
the practitioners that give the people
what they want
i think the worst approach and the worst
patient is the one that tells the
practitioner what to do botox is
expensive the actual substance is
expensive so
you should be careful by looking at the
price tag because
basically it means you either get
shortchanged or you get something else
or
it's possibly not a great not as great a
deal as it seems
the treatment i received was 895
pounds obviously that depends on
which clinic you go to and how many
areas you get treated
so i had my forehead and my jaw but i
know that
dr prager likes to treat the face as a
whole
so that everything looks really balanced
so this is the final result it takes
around three days to a week
to get the full effect i had the
treatment maybe
two or three weeks ago now so it's the
same thing that i have done every single
time and every single time the results
are the same so i know what to expect
i didn't get any bruising although i
suspect that with any kind of injectable
treatment
that is a possibility and if i was going
to
tell my friends about this treatment um
i would tell them honestly that yeah
it's a little painful when it's
happening but
in my experience i haven't had any
negative effects
the things i find most beautiful are
when someone is confident and happy
for me there is a lot of beauty in
revealing your true self
whether that be embracing how you look
or your body or
your personality share your stories and
ask as many questions as you like in the
comments